[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that
was the big bang well of course uh a
visual and audio illustration of the big
bang and the term big bang that is just
a human metaphor a term that we invent
to
try to describe something that none of
us has or ever will
experience and and that's a strategy
that we employ all the time i mean i'm a
physicist but also a writer and one of
the great challenges about writing about
physics is finding
the right metaphor the the right analogy
the right language describes some aspect
of cutting edge research
and i can't tell you the number of times
that readers of my books will come up to
me and they'll say hey you you use a
rubber sheet to describe the fabric of
space you use bread rising as it cooks
to describe the expansion of space you
talk about
jitters being infused into the
microscopic realm to talk about quantum
mechanics then they say but but how do
you how do you brian green actually
think about these ideas
my answer often is
i think about it in precisely those
terms i use these metaphors and thinking
about the actual science doing the
actual scientific research and this
capacity to use language to
describe things that we haven't seen is
something that we then go further on
using the tools of mathematics
but could mathematics itself just be
another language one that is
particularly well suited to articulating
pattern more generally still
is it the case that language so
thoroughly suffuses human thought that
it can be viewed
as the substrate
of human cognition and finally how can
it be
that swirls
on a page or sounds that we invent
can carry such power
we die
that may be
the meaning of life
but we do
language
that may be
the measure
of our lives
i can see that in the midst of death
life persists in the midst of untruth
truth persists in the midst of darkness
light persists
if nothing else
say this
is true
that even as we grieved we grew that
even as we hurt we hoped that even as we
tired we tried that we'll forever be
tied together victorious
not because we will never again know
defeat
but because we will never again
sow
division
now where
does this power come from was there some
singular rewiring of the human brain in
the ancestral past that gave rise
to language
is language something that we can
examine at work within the human brain
allowing us to understand its
relationship to other qualities of human
cognition
is language and adaptively selected tool
like domesticated fire or the hand acts
one that
builds communities and allows us to
achieve things as a collective
that would be unavailable to us
acting as individuals
and could it be
that that most iconic quality of
language metaphor
using a term that originated in one
context to tell us something about a
vastly different context could that
capacity
be the root of human intelligence could
that capacity explain how we prevailed
how we came to dominate
the planet
these are just some of the questions
that we are going to be investigating
here tonight with some of the leading
thinkers on the subject
gnome chomsky evelena federenco
daniel dorr
and stephen pinker
all right let's begin
with noam chomsky
six decades ago noam chomsky
revolutionized the field of linguistics
with the contention
that there was a genetic basis for our
capacity to acquire use and understand
language and that all languages have an
underlying common structure his theories
helped make professor chomsky one of the
most widely cited scholars in history
and his ideas are still the subject of
vigorous debate he joins us now from his
home in arizona
welcome professor chomsky
very pleased to be with you thank you
very much let's jump right in
famously
one of the
less celebrated co-discoverers of
evolution by natural selection alfred
russell wallace
he
was deeply skeptical of the possibility
of explaining human intelligence culture
language in particular through the use
of evolution by natural selection
instead he turned to a higher power as
the ultimate explanation
what was he
missing where did he go wrong in that
thinking
well
remember that was before
anything had been discovered about
genetics about mutation
about the way in which a
genome can give instructions to
a production system which is not very
well understood even now
but it does yield complex structures he
also was missing uh
the discoveries of
the theory of computation
girdle turing other great mathematicians
of the
20th century
established how
a finite device can have
infinite scope
you go back to
galileo say they were
galileo and his contemporaries were
quite properly amazed by
the fact that
with a small number of symbols
we can create infinitely many
thoughts
uh
and even convey to others who have
no access to our minds the inner
workings of our minds they
were wondered how this uh
achievement could be
realized that galileo himself thought
that the
alphabet was the most stupendous
invention
uh ever made because it was somehow able
to
record this capacity
but we now are beginning to grasp how
a very simple
restructuring of the brain maybe a small
mutation
could have led
to
the richness and complexity of
the capacity to produce
thoughts indefinitely and
optionally to convey them to others you
can get a grasp on that idea
so what do you feel is the
is the strongest evidence that there was
this mental rewiring when it comes to
language that there was something that
happened inside the brain of our
forebears that made them able to have
this capacity to acquire and to produce
language
well the strongest evidence is what
we're doing
it is a species property
it's now known that
this genomic analysis showing that
humans
who began to separate
at least 150 000 years ago
that's not very long an evolutionary
time
after the appearance of homo sapiens
maybe two or three hundred thousand
years ago which is a flick of an eye
before the appearance of homo sapiens
there's no evidence in the
archaeological record of any
significant symbolic activity
maybe a
cl you know a line on a bone or
something but
none of the complex symbolic activity
that you get
with the appearance of homo sapiens
so here we have a species property
common to human the
splits
the groups that split have the same
language faculty so that means it was in
place
prior to the separation
doesn't seem to have been in place
anywhere prior to homo sapiens
so it looks as if some small change took
place
well that's
side evidence the main evidence
is that
we can now
uh show at least for
significant parts of
language that you can account for them
on the basis of the assumption that
nature
picked
the simplest possible solution
when a generative
process appeared uh other there's no
analog in other organisms
so you can try very hard
has been tried to teach an ape
uh
something like language but it's
completely impossible and and are you
convinced or even surprised if you are
convinced that this happened once
and that then ceded this genetic change
throughout the species
should it perhaps happen multiple times
is it a very specific one-off chance
event that just endowed us with this
capacity
well if you look at
evolutionary history
lots of things have happened only once
by accident
so why aren't we all bacteria
because
by accident
one bacterium happened to swallow
another microorganism
which led to
structural changes
because of physical law
which led to eukaryotic cells which
means we have complex organisms uh
a human the appearance of humans
after almost four billion life years on
earth is
an enormous accident
um it could very well be that
there's no thought anywhere in the
universe other than this one accident we
have no evidence for it anywhere else
and
by now there's
work suggesting that the
probability of
anything like
complex intelligence even life is
extremely small within the accessible
universe physically accessible so for
all we know we're totally alone it's
just some accident and it occurred in
the last
instant of evolution on earth
so even if even if life turned out to be
relatively commonplace throughout the
universe which is a a possibility we
look at the number of stars and the
number of planetary systems and the
basic biochemistry necessary for life
if it comes to intelligent life and if
it comes to intelligent life that
harnesses the power of language
that
in your perspective could be a singular
event
in the cosmos we could be the only
life form that uses this mode of thought
and this mode of communication
that's uh quite possible in fact the
grand old man of uh american biology
ernst meyer
had an interesting debate which you may
have seen with carl sagan
on the
likelihood of
finding intelligent life and
sagan astrophysicists gave basically
your argument
all these stars all these planets why
shouldn't it appear everywhere
that's the fair famous fermi paradox
where are they uh
meyer arguing on the basis of
as a biologist
said let's look at the one case we have
uh humans that life's been on earth for
for roughly four billion years
if you look at the actual evolution
of humans you find accident after
accident
just happened i mentioned a couple like
an asteroid hit the earth and
wiped out the dinosaurs left a little
bit of space for small mammals to
develop okay ends up being us
uh and there's case after case like that
they said the chances of this happening
are extremely slight
but now there's even work
show indicating that
the complexity of
rna sequences is extremely
unlikely to appear
uh just by straight statistical um
measures so maybe there's nothing and
maybe it just happened and that's the
answer to fermi
they're not there okay so deeply lonely
a cosmic loneliness that uh may well be
how reality is constructed um so
focusing back here on on planet earth
one question that people
naturally ask when it comes to
the thought that
human language is so singular they point
to other
other species now you mentioned the
difficulty in teaching other animals
language but when it comes to you know
whale songs or or dolphins or you know
gesticulation among some of our primate
cousins you see that kind of
communication as
radically different from what we're
doing right now
well first of all that's communication
uh every species noun to bacteria
has modes of communication
but language is not just
we use it for communication of course
but it's basically an instrument of
thought
uh that was
[Music]
a long tradition
i mentioned galileo but many others just
assumed that language is
what was sometimes called horrible
thought it's the instrument of thought
now if you think about our own
like language in use that's almost all
we do is language is to construct
thoughts in our mind
sometimes we
externalize them sometimes we
communicate
but that's a kind of a side
property of language now by now we can
pin that down much more precisely
when you look at the
actual
design and structure of language
what you find systematically
is that if when there are
instances where there are conflicts
between
communicative efficiency
and
computational efficiency
computational efficiency always wins
uh there are very simple cases like uh
simple structural ambiguities
so if i say
flying planes can be dangerous
it's structurally ambiguous means the
act of flying or
the planes that fly
well the point is if you just let the
rules run freely
computational efficiency you get things
like this
but they harm communication
because
means can't understand what somebody's
saying do they mean
to fly planes or planes that fly and
there are many things like this some of
them
pretty serious
which impede communication
but mother nature didn't care
when
evolution moves along
some change takes place
you get the simplest solution
simplest most elegant solution
may happen to be dysfunctional
not mother nature's problem
you've got it and that's the way it
seems as language develop but just so i
can completely understand when you speak
of
language as a as a tool of thought are
you referring to the inner voice that we
all hear
inside of our heads or are you thinking
a more abstract version of language in
the thought process
well the what's called the inner voice
is actually an outer voice
if you think about
when you're
introspecting and using language in your
head
you can tell how long the sentences are
you can tell whether they rhyme
which means that you're hearing the
outers
you're hearing
external speech
with the articulatory organs disabled
but it's not what's inside
there's things going on in the mind
constructing thoughts which we can't
consciously access but which enter into
everything we do
like interpreting that sentence the way
we interpret it and this you find all
over
what's called inner speech is really
just
outer speech where you haven't bothered
to articulate it the inner speech you
can't access and that's going on we can
only see its effects and from its
effects you can
determine what it must be much like
anywhere else in the sciences
they do we we can't communicate the way
as well as other animals can
like you and i couldn't be taught
to imitate the waggle dance of bees
we're just not constituted to do that
bees do it instinctively it's a complex
system
so it's not a matter of
more advanced less advanced just
different paths
and these are modes of communication but
what's unique to humans is the capacity
for thought
so if but if one can introspect one's
way to the recognition
of
language as a tool of thought
and if the only thing that we have
access to as third-party investigators
is the externalization
of language i don't mean this as a
facetious question but how do we know
about the other animals only thing that
we really know is that they don't
externalize in the way that we do i mean
of course i i agree with you i don't
think that my dog is thinking about the
general theory of relativity or proust
or anything like that but
but if it's only the externalization
that differentiates us from a third
party perspective
how sure are we about that
well
in the empirical world we're never sure
there's no certainty there's only best
theories
construct the best theory again so i
have a dog two dogs sitting under the
desk and i can study the kinds of things
they do
sometimes
moderately complex
but if i
study their repertoire carefully
i think they have maybe
a dozen things
that they react to
there's no indication of anything else
going on
maybe there's something going on that we
have no indication of but
you could say that about an atom sure no
maybe thinking maybe they have thoughts
too no no i i and they're actually of
course there's some philosophers who
think that atoms do have have thoughts
well what we do is scientists just keep
to the best simplest theory we can find
people want to speculate about other
things okay but we have no reason to
believe it
but if if language then is is
fundamentally a tool of thought and
that's the basis of our thought did
wittgenstein have it right
is the limit of our language the limit
of our world
one issue is
whether
our
mental capacities
crucially language and thought but other
mental capacities
whether they have limits
so
is it the case as
many believe in including some great
scientists and mathematicians like
hilbert that everything is within our
capacity
every possible program problem we have a
way to solve
what's a possibility the other
possibility is we're organic creatures
like other organic creatures
our capacities have scope and limits
and that means there might well be
problems that we simply can't solve
and there might be uh
problems that we can't even formulate
because we don't have the right
cognitive apparatus well those are two
points of view
there's a separate issue
uh
which actually wittgenstein probably had
in mind it's the
sometimes called the superior warf
hypothesis
that the nature of our language
determines the way
that the particular language say english
not hopi
determines the way we perceive the world
that's a second separate hypothesis
the second one has been
investigated empirically for about 70
years by now
and there's very little evidence
if you look closely it turns out that
the
there seems to be
deep uniformity
in the way people think even if they
talk about it differently
so
on the second one i think it's
very dubious that there's
any significant impact on the of the
particular language the first one is a
much deeper problem
and it's
very hard to answer
how can we within
our framework of thought
determine whether there are problems we
can't even formulate
that's
not simple
i just want to quickly turn
for the last part of the conversation
here to
human creativity
a lot of people would look at that as
the iconic quality
of what our species is able to do come
up with novel solutions innovate
ingenuity when facing challenges
to what extent do you consider language
to be
the basis
of that creativity
well first of all there's
traditionally hundreds of years ago
there's two different kinds of
creativity distinguished
one of them
is the normal creativity
uh taking place at every moment of our
lives so just talking to each other
every time we're talking to each other
talking to a friend
at a bus stop
we're constructing
new expressions
maybe never before
appeared in the history of the language
the other person understands them that's
galileo's problem
the
constant creativity and innovation
in norman normal human life exhibited in
the construction of thought by language
and the occasional
interchange with them that's one kind of
creativity
then there's the kind you're talking
about now
what has uh
maybe aesthetic value
or new insights radical new insights
into the nature of the world
that second kind of creativity nobody
knows anything about
uh the first kind we can
get a partial grasp about but notice we
don't really have an explanation
for how it is that
you you and i are doing what we're now
doing
how can we can constantly construct new
thoughts
sometimes express them
appropriate to situations not caused by
situations
that was the problem that led descartes
to establish a
postulate a second substance
race cogitons which he connected to
thinking speech but connected to
thinking
nobody understands that
but uncertainty the higher form of
creativity we can
gesture at but there's no real
understanding of it but bear in mind
that
we don't even understand the most
elementary elements of voluntary action
like if i decide to lift my finger
why am i deciding uh
there's plenty of work in the
neurosciences on
the basis for voluntary action but
can't get this far but then when you
think of
language as a tool of thought are you
thinking of it as the exclusive tool of
thought or one of many tools that we use
i mean when beethoven was writing the
ninth symphony
was language driving that when einstein
was working out general relativity is
language driving that
well here there's a
comment of wittgenstein's which is
a posit i think
uh he says that uh
in his usual aphoristic style he says
uh humans think
maybe dolls and spirits
meaning uh
the word thinking the way we use it it's
something humans do
in language
uh sometimes there's kind of open
texture we are sometimes willing to
metaphorically extend
what humans do so maybe dolls and
spirits actually turing had something to
say about this too
in his famous paper on which
launched artificial intelligence can
machines think
uh he
opens the paper by saying the question
whether machines can think
is too meaningless to deserve discussion
because we have no concept of thought
except for human language and
its expression of thought
so if you ask when
i'm planning to drive to work and i pick
this path not another path
there's something going on but whether
you want to call it thought is like
asking whether submarine swim
you want to call that swimming okay but
it's not a substantive question so if i
was to ask you whether artificial
systems can or will ever think would you
give me turing's response
i would give you touring's response
if
if in fact he went on to say look if we
by machine of course event program if we
can construct a
program that would have
many of the properties of what humans do
we might be willing to
extend the metaphor and say yes they're
thinking the way we are but to ask the
question whether the
program thinks is
just doesn't mean anything we don't have
a concept of thinking that's independent
of
what humans do
uh
with the use of language so it's kind of
there's a lot of philosophical
controversy about it but it's idle
it's like having a controversy about
whether
airplanes really fly
in some languages you say they fly some
languages say they glide and some
doesn't but there's no substantive
question it's a question about what
metaphor was willing to accept
and and would you even apply that and
perhaps
you would if i was to ask do you think
it's possible for some artificial system
that we create
to have some kind of inner world not
even applying the word think per se but
just some kind of inner experience in a
world does that fall into the same
category of questions that it's kind of
meaningless to answer from your
perspective
it's not meaningless but it's based on
discoveries which haven't been made
what is it that gives us experience
nobody knows
at some
level of complexity
the brain does
have the capacity
to give us
an awareness of things around us
conscious awareness
nobody has any idea what this is even
where it is
i mean
neuroscientists assume it's
something about neural nets
uh
people working in deep learning use that
model
but it may be completely the wrong model
uh there is
uh randy gallistell's one
outstanding neuroscientist cognitive
neuroscientist who's
argued i think pretty persuasively
that neural nets in principle
do not have the
elementary element
required for a touring machine
computational device so you have to look
somewhere else and they've now even
found evidence that
internal to cells
you get computational properties
the the cerebellum has huge cells
perkinj cells and there's some evidence
that internal to those cells
you're finding computation going on
conditioning going on and so on and it
could be and of course there's massive
computational capacity once you get into
cellular structure so maybe neuroscience
is just looking in the wrong place now
we'll have to have some
totally new direction here but we're
moving into areas where
you know there's a lot of
scattered evidence but no deep
understanding
so one final question as we reach the
end here you've had a long career with
profound impact in so many areas
your own field linguistics but cognitive
science political thought
governmental structures and so on
as you look to the future
do you have a sense of optimism about
where we as a language wielding thinking
species are headed or
a sense of pessimism
well we're a
thinking species maybe the only one
but we're not thinking very well
let's face the
situation that now exists
there is
a major crisis coming
there's an environmental crisis which is
marching forward we know
we have a grasp about
what
can be done
to arrest
cataclysm
but we're not taking the steps
we know what they are
we're not taking the steps
in fact that's even true on narrower
questions
one of the things if
some
extraterrestrial intelligence if there
is one is watching us
would think we're insane i mean take
something as simple as the covid crisis
every
state
every country
developed countries scientists leaders
understand very well
that unless they provide vaccines to
africa and asia
poor countries in latin america
the virus is going to mutate
it'll lead to
probably lethal developments it'll come
back and strike us
are they giving them the vaccines no
we are so consumed by
greed
and
commitment to
maintain profits for pharmaceutical
corporations that leaders all around the
world are saying okay let's commit
suicide
i mean that's what we're watching
is that a thinking creature
of a global warming it's much more
serious
um coven get over somehow
global the melting of the arctic uh
the polar ice caps we if it's there
what's done you know
and we're watching it and not solving
the problem so we know how to solve it
so is that a thinking creature
if you extrapolate
future doesn't look too bright
so uh there may actually be no at the
moment thinking creatures in the
universe to some extent but let's hope
let's hope that future generations will
look back and not draw that conclusion
it's been an honor to speak with you
professor chomsky thank you so much for
joining us
thank you
the origins and function of language are
the subject of intense debate among
linguists
but what can the brain itself tell us
about what language is and where it
comes from
evalina federenco is an associate
professor in the department of brain and
cognitive sciences and the mcgovern
institute for brain research at mit
where she runs a research lab devoted to
studying the cognitive and neural
mechanisms of language she joins us from
her home
outside of boston welcome ev
also joining us now is daniel dorr
professor at the dan department of
communication tel aviv university he's a
linguist and the author of the
instruction of imagination language as a
social communication technology in which
he argues that language is a
collectively inventive tool that allows
us to harness the power
of imagination he joins us now from his
home
outside of tel aviv welcome daniel
so
thank you for joining us so noam chomsky
has laid out his perspective which you
both are already intimately familiar
with
that language is fundamentally a tool of
thought and only in a peripheral sense
is it a mechanism a means a medium of
communication now as i understand it
both of you
have a very different perspective
on the fundamental role of language just
to get us going daniel what do you
consider to be
the fundamental purpose the fundamental
role of language well first of all it's
a tool of communication pure and simple
it's not a tool of
thought but what makes is it's different
from other tools of communication that
we use and the
other animals use
is the fact that language opens a
totally new channel for communication
for us
that no other system opens and let me
very briefly
describe what this is when you look at
all the other systems of communication
that animals use and that we use
what you see is that those systems allow
us to present our interlocutors with
materials to perceive with their senses
so i show you a picture you see the
picture i play music for you you hear
the music i hug you you feel the hug
language doesn't work that way if i uh
tell you about an event that i
participated in um the other day you
don't see the event or feel it or hear
it what actually happens is that you
imagine the event inside your mind and
the way you do that
is by taking my words and the structural
connections between them
and using them in order to get from your
long-term memory clusters of experiences
that are related to the words and then
rearrange them according to the
structures of my sentences to create an
imagined com
experience
inside your mind and what that has
allowed humans to do for hundreds of
thousands of years now
uh is to communicate about stuff that
you cannot show
stuff that you cannot present to the
sentence to the senses
and that includes stuff from the past
stuff from other places
talking about the future that doesn't
yet exist at all talking about stuff
that just simply doesn't exist and it
also very very importantly it allows us
for the first time
to communicate about mental dynamics
questions that we have ideas that we
have arguments that we want to get into
and to
create
a sort of collective consciousness a
sort of
larger brain made out of all our
different brains that allow us to think
in totally different ways but
the way language contributes to thinking
is not by
helping us individually to think in ways
that are different
the way language helps us is by allowing
us to do parallel computing by allowing
us
to
connect our brains on a network of
thinking and i think that every big
thing that humanity has done and
including all the bad things that are
big
are the result of the fact that we no
longer only think by ourselves and that
is the thing that language has helped us
do it has created an entire domain
of collective imagination
where we all live
which characterizes our life our lives
much more deeply
than this property or the other of our
individual brains
so ev do you do you have a similar view
that that unlike chomsky's perspective
language is not
a tool of thought primarily and in
particular if you do hold that view i'm
wondering
if you can address
one of the arguments that chomsky has
put forward which is
every time it comes to a kind of
competition between efficiency and
computation and efficiency and
communication
he argues that the computation seems to
win out which suggests that primarily
that is where language has its
fundamental home
in the nature of thought
uh yes so um i find the question of the
relationship between language and
thought obviously deep and important and
it's a question that drew me to science
but i am a very strong empiricist and i
like testable ideas and to the extent
that
one wants to argue that language shares
machinery or mediates something like
complex thought and reasoning abilities
we should be able to evaluate it and we
should be able to see if that's on the
right track and so for the last
decade or so
i've been trying to evaluate that idea
and it just seems like there is um no
support for it from all sorts of um
approaches so
uh in the human brain the system that
works right now in your brain as you're
understanding what i'm saying and in my
brain as i'm generating this is
absolutely silent when we're thinking
logically when we're doing math when
we're doing kind of common sense
reasoning about object properties event
properties in the world and
you
so
on
silent just so i understand you mean
it's like not lighting up in exactly
some kind of mri yeah
exactly whatever measures we have to um
uh measure brain activity which is it's
an indirect measure but it has been
linked to cell firing at some very um
basic level
and so the language system just doesn't
do anything whereas other parts of the
brain are working really hard so it's
not like
something in the brain is doing that
work obviously it's just not the same
system that allows us to produce and
understand utterances now you can also
take individuals with severe language
damage so these are individuals who have
you know grown up and their brains are
well formed and working well and then
suddenly they have a something like a
major stroke to the
one of the big arteries that supports
the parts of the brain that
underlie language ability and these
people um so that's a syndrome known as
global aphasia so it's a very very
severe linguistic deficit these
individuals cannot produce language they
cannot understand language and yet
they can play chess and they can do
sudoku puzzles and they can think very
very complex thoughts about the world
suggesting that language is no longer
is not needed at least once the brain is
fully formed
and so empirically just doesn't seem
like there's any evidence for this link
between linguistic processing and
thought it could have been that way it's
just not
and and and in those examples
are you measuring the individual's
lack of language capacity through the
inability to speak or you're also doing
it through
examining what's happening inside of the
brain while they're say playing chess
can you have someone playing chess in an
fmri machine you can make it so but um
uh a lot of these individuals have
conditions which actually prevent them
from being like a lot of them have
pacemakers and other things that make
them unable to undergo fmri but so you
assess them behaviorally but you're not
just tapping the kind of surface output
structure we have tests we as a field of
language research has developed tests
over the years that allow us to tap uh
what kind of knowledge representations
are retained and the best we can tell um
the the language system was effectively
gone and if you just look at the extent
of damage it's basically the whole
cortical
chunk uh that supports language is gone
in those people it's not like a subtle
little
lesion there it's a massive massive
damage and so and and you do not think
in those cases that there's some kind of
individual rewiring that allows the
individual to
undertake certain cognitive tasks that
ordinarily might involve language but in
their case the brain has found a way to
avoid that damaged region
um
well combined with fmri evidence i don't
think that's likely because otherwise in
your typical individuals in you and me
for example um the language brave each
should be working hard when we're
engaging in complex thought right so the
fact that they don't seems unlikely but
even so um the argument would still
stand that complex thought is possible
without language even if it somehow
moved around in the brain and it's not
quite the same as a neurotypical yeah
absolutely so so daniel what about the
argument that chomsky gives in terms of
the the intrinsic structure of language
somehow favoring the computational
qualities as opposed to the
communicative qualities when you look at
the design features of language itself
let me let me uh take a step back
and and say something about the
structures of language from my point of
view i think that as long as you think
like professor chomsky you're thinking
in this way or the other in terms of the
computer metaphor there's this
computer on our
on our shoulders
and this computer is a computational
machine it does all kinds of things and
the idea is language is a sort of
software
inside that
computer i think that everything we've
learned in the last 50 years
actually tells us
tells us that we should finally
replace our metaphors and move from the
computer metaphor to what we may think
of as the internet metaphor language
resides on the net it is a property of
the community
the structural properties that you find
in language when you actually get your
hands dirty and do the linguistic
analysis
what they reflect is an entire history
of social negotiations within a culture
within a community
about what we need from language as a
tool of communication how to structure
it
and once you think about language um as
something that resides on the internet
like facebook or tiktok
then you can see that we as individuals
are end users we are not our brain is
not the site of language we are end
users of language and there's a lot of
fascinating stuff that we need to that
we already know and a lot of stuff that
we need to discover about what happens
in our brains
as end users
but i think that the most important
thing for me as a linguist is that once
you look at the structures of language
and you start thinking about them in
terms of interaction in terms of the
relationships between speakers and
listeners
in terms of the different interests of
speakers and listeners
you can actually explain the structures
much much better and you don't need to
stipulate
stuff of the of the stuff that we've
heard of the type that we've heard that
for example
sentences that are ambiguous in language
actually emerge inside the mind as a
non-ambiguous sentence i think this is
something that just doesn't make any
sense
if you think in terms of the
relationships between speakers and
listeners you can see for example
that speakers and listeners have
different interests in the story
as far as you're concerned
you would
best prefer to say a word or two and let
me figure out everything else as a
listener do all the work by myself
that's what sometimes happens in
intimate situations right
a good friend asks you
what happened in the meeting and you say
oh it was okay because you understand
that the other person can
put in all the other information
for me as a listener when i listen to
you my preference is for you to put
everything correctly and right and with
all the details so i don't have to work
hard
to
guess what you meant and between those
different interests
we come up with a certain compromise not
just you and me the whole history of the
community with the language a certain
compromise that actually determines the
logic of the structures
and we as individuals who are end users
do not have to represent all this logic
in our minds
we just have to be able to use
language the way we use
facebook which means that just like you
cannot understand facebook on the basis
of what's happening in your own computer
you have to look at the network
the same thing is also true for language
so if if language is as you say
fundamentally a tool of communication
then ev for instance would you
argue
that it has a relationship to other
tools of communication that we do
see in the animal kingdom from look i
can't talk without my hands flying into
motion right and and there are various
other facial expressions and things that
we do is language a kind of natural next
step
in that progression of communication
strategies
i think so i mean i think we um have
lots of prior reasons to think that
there is biological continuity in
general but in terms of what we know
from studying um modern day modern day
humans that does seem to be a deeper
link between the systems that support
social perception uh and cognition and
language compared to the systems that
support kind of abstract complex
reasoning and language um and the
evidence comes uh in a few different
forms
from the fact that um the general
topography so how the landscape of
activation in our brains elicited by
linguistic processing versus social
processing are similar or parallel they
are distinct so as i mentioned the
language system is actually quite
specialized for processing language so
it doesn't it's not active when we
engage in complex thought or when we
think about others mental states or
imagine their faces or gestures and so
on
but the regions that support those other
social functions are right next door to
the regions that support language
processing and that gives rise to this
interesting possibility that
evolutionarily maybe there were kind of
broader regions attuned to social
stimuli because we are social species
very deeply in you know very fundamental
ways that this last year has made
perhaps uh abundantly clear um and it's
made it more clear to me than i than i
would have thought before yes same and
um eventually as we got more and more
complex and the relevant parts of the
brain expanded because this is the kind
of what's known as the association
cortex so it's cortex that's not
primarily involved in perception or
motor control so it's basically the
cortex that does all the interesting
cognitively complex stuff
as it expanded
and became more complex in humans we now
have this fractionation into some parts
that say perceived faces some parts that
perceive gestures right or body language
and some parts that actually store
mappings between some symbolic
representations like words and meanings
in the world right because that's
effectively what language is is a system
that allows us to map some aspect of the
world some object some type of event
onto a string of sounds or a string of
signs if we're talking about sign
language but um i think there is um a
lot of suggestive evidence that language
and social cognition are very deeply
linked so so daniel can you give us a a
a brief history if you will of
the steps by which you imagine
language
was brought into the world through
whatever
pre-linguistic modes of communication
our forebears may have been struggling
with and then language resolved this
design issue of how
to bring the level of communication to a
higher place
i i i think that
you got a tail there of three parts
the the first part basically starts in
the cambrian explosion a half a billion
years ago when brains actually began to
evolve
and what you see through a very very
long process of mental cognitive
emotional evolution
our brains that are specialized in all
kinds of ways for different animals
for what you may call private
experiencing the brain is supposed to be
the commander of behavior of the
individual carrying it
all right
and and this is something that is true
as far as we can tell of all animals
maybe apart from social insects
even when animals live together socially
even when they cooperate
you don't get mental cognitive
cooperation in the sense that you don't
get parallel computing
individual animals do all the
computations they need inside their own
head
sometime around two million years ago in
homo erectus or maybe in abilis you
start to see in the archaeological
evidence
signs that human communities
broke a barrier and they broke the
barrier of private experiencing and
moved to a mode of collective
experiencing using memetic tools of
communication that include pointing and
eye contact and demonstrations with the
hands and all kinds of stuff like that
where individuals within the here and
now of the shared experience could start
to compute together to think together
and this worked wonderfully for a
million and a half years but it turned
out probably that the needs for more and
more communication for
parallel computing
became more and more severe and at some
point as far as i can tell
human communities broke a second barrier
first they broke the barrier of private
experiencing and moved to collective
experience and and now they broke the
barrier of experiencing
and went beyond that into collective
imagination
and once
collective imagination proved to be such
a useful thing for human communities
because it did very very quickly it
opens your possibilities in unbelievable
ways
uh you got into this
spiral of co-evolutionary dynamic
in which communities languages and
individuals
co-evolved with each other
and within this process
individual brains came to be selected
for their ability to participate in the
social linguistic game
so that eventually we're today in a
situation where you have communities
very dependent on language you have
full-fledged languages and you have
language-ready brains
language-ready brains in the sense that
the brain
the whole thing
is capable of
um
recruiting enough brain energy in order
to meet the challenge of language
acquisition
uh without there being any universal
grammar or set of formal rules
that are somehow given to us
in our genes because evolutionarily
speaking this idea doesn't make sense
then ev would you then
come to the conclusion that
if
we at some point make contact with
extraterrestrial life
that we shouldn't be surprised
that they have some form of
communication because presumably in
order for them to make some sort of
contact with us in some form they had to
work as a group and therefore would have
the very same social pressures that
daniel was just talking about and then
that would naturally yield
to communication of the sort that
vaguely we're familiar with as opposed
to say chomsky's perspective where
there's a good chance perhaps that we're
the sole thinking linguistic species in
the universe
yeah
yeah i think that's unlikely i mean um i
you know i have no stake in this i i
can't assess the likelihood i mean i can
guess based on the numbers of planets
that are out there but um uh yeah i
think if there is a species um
some kind of biological species that
have
enough of a social bias to interact with
each other and a sophisticated enough
internal world then of course they're
gonna find a way to share information
because you are empowered when you can
do things together right you can protect
your group better jointly you can share
knowledge with offspring i mean you can
do all sorts of things that you couldn't
do and of course you can um you know
invent calculus and figure out how to
fly to other planets and things like
that so language is certainly empowering
but i think thought development uh
fundamentally precedes language
so daniel ev made an interesting
remark there in terms of say inventing
calculus that makes my ears perk up
because i'm one who uses calculus in in
my day-to-day life
is calculus and just view calculus of
course as a representative of
what the human mind human creativity is
able to accomplish
is that an example of instructing the
imagination going overboard
have we sort of just swung past
the utility of
imagination instruction into a place
which is fascinating
but is really just an over swinging of
that capacity
i don't think it's an overswinging of
the capacity but i think that
something slightly different is
happening there
one of the most important things for me
is that once you look at language at the
right ontological level as a system of
communication
you start looking and you start seeing
the fact that just like any other tool
it fails on us from time to time it has
weaknesses
it doesn't always work very well
and the
foundational reason why it sometimes
fails us
is the following you have your own
experiential world that you live in and
i have my own
and they're not the same we're not the
same person
and when we use the same language for
example english
we get this sense which is sometimes
illusory
that your words mean the same thing that
they mean to me and because of that very
often you'll say something i'll think i
understood you but it turned it will
turn out that i didn't and we'll get all
kinds of misunderstandings so i think
that once language is there you start a
process which is again collective
innovative
of trying to brush the thing
to get it to be more and more precise
it's one of the
huge forces that plays there
and i think that
all the stuff that you guys physicists
and math and mathematicians work with
are tools
that
uh uh you guys the tradition managed to
make
to make
so precise
managed to make so unambiguous
that you eventually were able to
discover all kinds of fascinating things
about the world as a result of that
process of
honing the meanings
so i don't think it's a different story
i think it's one of the different
dynamics that emerged from
the fact that we started to communicate
and in day-to-day communication
uh people who are doing um a work in
conversational analysis for example nick
enfield
is a very important person there
they can show you in a regular
conversation that sometimes we spend
more than 50 percent of our time of
conversation
repairing misunderstandings
exactly because language is not that
ideally designed
tool that chomsky is talking about it is
something that our ancestors
invented hundreds of thousands of years
ago when they still use stone tools
and it is a very tentative system it's
ingenious but it's also tentative so
mathematics is one of those places
where the entire developmental process
that we humans went through got us to a
place where
yes our words one two three plus minus
have come to be so precise that now you
can use them as wonderful tools for the
understanding of the world
so just to be clear you you are saying
and i agree with this perspective
you are saying that math is a language
i am saying that math is a language in
the sense that
in in the way you guys use it
the people who use language uh to work
with i think that
one of the
failures of educational systems
is that
children are taught mathematics
in a way that doesn't
go all the way to turning it into a
system of communication for these kids
right um
but but yes
so ev
one of the other
ideas that flows from
chomsky's perspective that there was
this
singular mental rewiring as he described
it that allowed us to have this capacity
to acquire language that gives a nice
explanation for why there is such a deep
similarity between
the world's languages after all any kid
can learn any language and the reason
for that would be that this mental
rewiring is latching on to this
universal quality that's common to all
languages without that what do you
consider to be
the the strongest explanation for why
there is this deep similarity between
the world's languages
well first of all i think the similarity
should not be overestimated um and a lot
of um work in the trump skin tradition
has been done on english and all the
examples they'll
tell you come from english so there's
actually drastic difference in how the
world sound systems lexicons
structures
are
that said there is a set of common
universals if you wish but these
universals are all to do with cognitive
and communicative efficiency so they
make our production system efficient
they make it easy for you to select
words and put them together in quickly
and
robustly so that
any comprehender can extract meaning
from those utterances and on the
comprehender's side on the side of
understanding we have mechanisms that
allow to fill in the gaps in the signal
just like um
dan was saying where um you know we can
uh extract very rich meanings from very
minimal linguistic input now what i
think makes the human brain language
ready
is in part just its size
i think that's something that's been
very undervalued uh in language research
where somehow the idea of some new brain
region emerging that can support some
fundamentally new computation has found
a lot of appeal but from everything we
know about biology and neuroscience um
it just doesn't look like this and the
evidence that has now found all sorts of
homologies between human brains and
brains of other primates and so um
i think this ability to store a vast
number of these mappings between forms
and meanings is something that is
grossly under a pre has been grossly
underappreciated i think it's now
getting more attention and the standard
argument is you know my dog can learn
some words yes but it cannot learn 10
000 words it cannot learn 100 000 words
and humans capacity to be able to encode
these very vast numbers of
symbolic representations that they can
use to
talk to each other about a vast number
of ideas
i think that's a uniquely powerful
capacity that has enabled a lot of what
we see in the world today i'm always i'm
always fond and i give the example of my
dogs being smart but i i i don't think
that they
speak physics or understand general
relativity but every time i say that i
do wonder if they're off in the corner
barking among themselves and saying how
silly those humans are we've got the
unified theory and they haven't even
gotten there gotten there yet but yes
daniel you uh had a remark on that i i
think that th this whole idea
that languages are essentially more
similar to each other than they are
different from each other
this is one of the greatest mistakes and
i think that now we're eventually in a
situation
where researchers actually do
comparative studies using a lot of
computer power for analysis
over hundreds and hundreds of languages
you have 6 000 languages around the
world and on every level
that you want to look at syntax and
morphology and phonetics and what have
you
you see
more and more remarkable differences and
if you put into it
not just the spoken languages but signed
languages which are languages for you
know all purposes
and you even
put into the story prototype languages
that are now being investigated where
people who are deaf and blind
communicate by tapping
you see that on all the structural
levels there are huge differences
between languages this is actually one
of the most important things in the
whole story
if you go
all over the world
and you meet people and you communicate
with them with facial expression and
pointing you can go very far you can say
pointing is indeed a universal thing
but
there's no language in the world that
you can speak
that you can use to speak to more than
20 30 percent of the population
of the world and if you really want to
get
a window into human nature you're not
going to find it in what is
shared by all languages which is very
very little
you're going to find it exactly in the
sense that the human species has managed
to find
6 000 different solutions
to the same basic engineering
problem
of how are we going to be able to
communicate with each other and instruct
each other's imagination the window to
our nature is in the diversity between
languages not in whatever putative
universal there is there because there
aren't many
i mean does it disturb you then that the
world is losing so many languages at
such a rapid rate definitely i think
this is one of the most worrying things
that uh we have to think about
uh according to some estimates of the 6
000 languages that we have today around
the world
approximately 90
will be lost by the end of this century
and i think it's a huge worry and of
course there's a lot of
sociological political reasons for that
and very often you see this
beautiful beautiful language with such
strange engineering solutions that you
never even thought about a product of
ingenuity
uh
that
right now you have you know 10 speakers
20 speakers 100 speakers
and
we're definitely
losing
together with those languages that are
dying we're losing
traditions of thought about the world
that are very very important beautiful
inspiring and so on and so forth so yes
it's a very very good
very serious reason for worry
yep ev why don't you take the last word
as we wind it up here sure i i mean i
just wanted to um disagree a little bit
in saying that i don't think it's
uninteresting to try to understand which
properties of languages are similar
because there are certainly parallels in
how humans have solved these problems of
communicating you know infinitely well
don't have to go to infinity a large
number of meanings okay um but i think
what these universals to the extent that
they have been discovered have told us
is that all of these constraints are
basic cognitive constraints there are
constraints from memory limitations from
how our attention works from how far we
can predict into the future for how we
hold on to information and package it
and um abstract away from the input to
more generalized things and i think that
tells you
again um
that it's not very likely that language
kind of emerged as this little snowflake
in our brains and suddenly everything
was different it was built on the very
basic fundamental components of neural
computation that characterize many many
species um that are you know lower on
the evolutionary dream
and so the one final question i said it
was going to be the last one we asked
one more as you look to the to the
future
then maybe each of you can just give a
brief answer daniel what do you see
as the next major thing on the horizon
and studying human language
i think that
once we manage to go through
the the conviction
that uh language is this way or the
other not a tool of communication and we
manage to settle on what we find
empirically as part of our scientific
work
and we managed to start looking at the
way communities have built languages
and we start looking at the histories
and the way they interact with cognitive
capacities
we get to know more and more about the
differences and similarities between
languages and
we get to understand more and more of
the evolutionary dynamics that have
characterized this because we haven't
talked about evolutionary developmental
psychology for example the whole
biology story of evo devo evolutionary
developmental biology
we understand the
co-evolutionary dynamics now
in a much much better way
and i think that once we really
understand the diversity of languages
and we really understand the dynamics of
the brain together i think will have a
sort of
first step towards a unified theory of
language
that is realistic and i think that's the
goal
ev how about you look into the future
yeah um so to circle back a little bit
to um deep learning and artificial
neural networks i've been incredibly
excited by the developments and in
computation artificial intelligence um i
think the models that exist these days
um that are language models
are exquisitely good at language they're
often criticized but what they're
criticized for is their inability to
think
now they're not trained to think they're
trained to predict the next word in a
sequence and uh now that we've shown
in our work and some related work that
the system that supports language
comprehension and production is actually
quite separate from the system that
supports thinking abstract kind of
hierarchical uh relationships among all
sorts of elements be it in math or in
common sense reasoning
we can utilize these language models
along with trying to build models of
thought which quite a few people are
trying to do and then if we you know
understand how those fit together then
we have a more complete um computational
explicit model of how the human brain
may be solving these problems and then
we can probe these systems to really
understand what are the representations
that we store what are the algorithms
that apply when we generate a sequence
or we generate a thought right
and um and that can have all sorts of
profound clinical implications
educational applications because if we
can build a system and make it do um
something that humans do well i think
that's quite powerful and now some
people have argued following uh daniel's
comments that maybe you want to build
systems that from early on are built to
interact with each other uh because that
may provide some features that just
wouldn't emerge ordinarily from if you
just construe it as a kind of singular
uh organism um and i think that's a
that's also a very exciting direction
yeah it absolutely is wonderfully
exciting so daniel dora evelina
federenko thank you both so much for
joining us a fascinating conversation
that was great thank you very much for
having me
stephen pinker is the johnstone
professor of psychology at harvard
university he conducts research on
language cognition and social relations
and is the author of
12 wonderful books including the
language instinct the stuff of thought
and the better angels of our nature
books from which i and many others of
course have been deeply influenced he
joins us now from his home in boston
welcome steve how are you doing
great thanks how are you brian good
great to see you
so we've had some discussion earlier in
the program about the origins of
language and the purpose and the role of
language and there's been a variety of
perspectives and i think it's
well caught by a phrase that guy
dutcher a colleague of yours he wrote
some time ago where he described the
impressive range of theories circulating
for how the first words emerge from
shouts and calls
from hand gestures sign language from
the ability to imitate from the ability
to deceive from grooming from singing
dancing rhythm from chewing sucking
licking and from almost any other
activity under
the sun so
i gather part of the issue here of
course is that words don't fossilize
they don't leave an imprint in the
physical world that we can examine the
way we can other structures and the
evolutionary records so from your view
where does that ultimately leave us will
we ever have an answer to the question
of the origin of language
i don't think you'd ever say we won't
have an answer to the question right now
we don't have an answer to the question
i think as with
many questions about the evolutionary
function and origin of a trait the
function is often more obvious than the
origin so for example there's not a
whole lot of mystery as to why we have
kidneys they filter out the blood while
we have lungs they oxygenate the blood
where the kidney came from or where the
lung came from
was it a swim bladder or was it
something else it's not exactly the same
question the digressions are related but
even if you don't know where the kidney
originated
that is what was the precursor structure
you really do know that it filters the
blood
likewise with language i think it's
pretty clear that it's there to exchange
ideas and to negotiate social
coordination what the first word was is
a much harder question to answer and and
so but right there there's a bit of a
controversy i guess because noam chomsky
famously
says that language is really a tool of
thought and
quite peripheral it's a tool of
communication what's what's your stance
on that
i i think it's a a a radical an extreme
and a rather implausible position uh for
one thing if language was primarily a
medium of thought
why why do we have words that can be
pronounced out loud
why is it the entire component of
language called phonology namely the
mapping from
uh symbols to motor commands in speech
or sign and
in the other direction the
acoustic phonology the ability to parse
sound waves or in the case of sign
language manual and facial gestures back
into the words so that would be a
complete mystery if language was a
medium of thought where
it's in your head that all you would
need is to be able to register the
symbols why do you have to pronounce
them also
why would words have to be conventional
why couldn't i have an idiosyncratic
representation of of dog and plate and
couch and sun and moon why is my
representation the same as your
representation if all we were doing with
those words was thinking thoughts
because the thoughts could stay inside
each of our skulls
so the fact that
that
is two of the most salient and universal
features of language namely there are
conventions uh if i have the subject
before the verb before the object so do
you if we belong to the same community
that would be a coincidence it was just
a way to think and the fact that we can
pronounce words uh would also be a
coincidence if language is just a way to
think well presumably chomsky would say
that
language has become a tool of
communication as well as a tool of
thought but its primary purpose where it
began
was in thought maybe the qualities that
you're describing emerged as language
was used in that way
but that was
a secondary use as opposed to a primary
use is there any thing in that that
strikes you as as plausible
no because if you're simply talking
about a system of mental representation
of having thoughts and a
system of inferring one thought from
another and there are no shared symbols
and there's no way of getting it in or
out of the skull then it's
no then i wouldn't call it language
that's thought uh and indeed of course
in chomsky's own theory there is a level
of representation of meaning he called
typically calls it logical form
and
that is
almost continuous with thought to the
and presumably a lot more universal than
the particulars of a of a given language
or indeed of logical form belonging to a
particular language but if you're
talking about it may just be a matter of
as we say semantics in the sense of
meanings of words but a system of simply
of having thoughts is just not what we
mean when we use the word language and
and so when you think about language as
a tool of communication
is it general purpose communication or
for instance like daniel dorr emphasizes
language as really a tool to say
instruct the imagination of the other
very specific role that he believes
language played in the ancestral past
and the reason why we have it
it is not our a uh our only
channel of communication and there are
some things that it's good at
communicating others not so good
one of the reasons we have facial
expressions is that there are
emotional
colorations that are difficult to put
into words one of the reasons that we
have gesture and pantomime
is that there are spatial configurations
motion configurations that are very hard
to convey in words precisely because
language is is digital we've got words
they we
don't stretch out words more for bigger
things and shrink them for smaller
things they're they're just you you pick
one word or you pick another word and we
we order them from from uh
early to late in the sentence
that's excellent for conveying who did
what to whom
uh what where and why
not so good for conveying high
dimensional analog relationships it's
virtually impossible to say to define
something like a spiral without going
well you know it's like this if you
can't move your hands you're gonna have
a hard time using words to tell someone
where spiral is and so on for an
infinite number of other concepts on the
other hand language is it is very
general purpose in the sense that for
example a subject needn't be the agent
of an action we can say you know john
sustained an injury we can say the syst
the situation justifies drastic measures
the verb doesn't necessarily refer to an
action the object is not necessarily
something acted upon even though
prototypically they are
so
there is a kind of
generic set of semantic relations that
language is
optimized to convey
uh highly useful not specific to any
activity like eating or having sex or
running
on the other hand it is not identical
with the thoughts we have and the
thoughts we want to share
now you've also noted that
you see language as being
part of the way that we humans fill the
cognitive niche
can you explain the role that language
played in that and and what what do you
mean by that particular place that our
species has has filled
yeah it's a a concept that i borrowed
i.e stole from
john tube irv devore and lita cosmetics
and it pertains to the fact that
humans are zoologically really really
weird they're things that you see in
homo sapiens that are
rudimentary at best perhaps non-existent
in other species language being the most
obvious but not the only one we also are
very unusual among animals in the degree
to which we cooperate among
non-relatives
easy to explain cooperation among
kinship among kittens they share genes
not as easy to
explain cooperation among non-kin who
can much more easily exploit each other
we also are
have a lot of technological know-how
we're not the only species that
that makes tools but we depend on them a
whole lot more than any other species
tools that are not part of an innate
repertoire but that we
uh we invent we pass down culturally
now uh
devore and tube and cosmetics suggest
that these three
uh zoologically unusual traits and they
listed a number of others
are uh it's no coincidence that you find
them in the same species because each
one multiplies the value of the other
two
so it's not so easy to negotiate social
contracts agreements if you do this for
me i'll do that for you without language
not impossible but but very inefficient
it's not impossible to convey
technological know-how how do you
extract a poison from a plant and
prepare it so you could put it on the
tip of an arrowhead how do you fashion
vines into a baby sling
language is is pretty helpful
for that as well
and
in terms of getting
social cooperation going the
evolutionary theory tells us that the
cooperation
is uh easiest to evolve when it's
possible to confer a big benefit to
someone else at a small cost to oneself
because that sets up a kind of a market
a kind of economy of favor trading uh
you you don't get that started if it's
just one uh cow say pulling up a lump of
grass and dropping it in front of
another cow the second cow could say
well thanks i can get my own grass
but when it comes to know-how
just in a few seconds of breath it costs
me virtually nothing and i can give you
a an invaluable skill
and so
uh the uh language uh ideas can be
duplicated at uh
trivial cost we're seeing that of course
in the digital revolution where you can
make perfect copies of things
at minimal cost
it goes way back and
the
ability to
share ideas means there is
much more reason for people to be as we
say on speaking terms namely uh
you uh hang out with other people be if
you have language
and if they have something to say to you
that is language evolved because we have
something to say and we're on speaking
terms
and and vice versa we're on speaking
terms because we have language and we
have something to say because we have
language language also allows you in the
technical sphere
to pool innovations so not everyone has
to invent the wheel that people can
improve on other inventions you can pass
it down to your kids you can share it
with others and so it's uh they probably
co-evolve we
have reason to believe that some degree
of
cooperation and know-how probably got
the cycle going simply because we see
them in in chimpanzees our closest
relatives and we don't see language in
them
but it may have kind of primed a pump
and created a kind of virtuous circle
where each one made the other two more
valuable right now
among the other things that certainly
seem quite special to the species
we can investigate the universe we can
write down laws of physics
we can
write novels i mean there are all sorts
of qualities of the world that you can
trace back in one way or another to the
emergence of language so a natural next
question is
how do we leverage language into these
abstract realms of thought and that
naturally takes us to the subject of
metaphor
and i'd like to turn to that now
and look i mean we both write books for
general audiences i find all the time
the exercise of writing a book is
finding the right metaphor the right
analogy for communicating abstract ideas
to general audiences i also find i'll
come back to this in a moment that
actually in my research work metaphors
are actually valuable even right there
and trying to push the boundaries of
understanding but one thing that was
really surprising to me
is the ubiquity of metaphors in the
language many of which you know are
hidden i mean if you if you focus your
attention you realize that our language
is just stuffed full of metaphors and of
course right there there were two bad
metaphors right of focusing attention we
focus telescopes we don't focus our
brain you know we stuff turkeys we stuff
draws in general we don't do it with
metaphors so so it's all it's all over
the place i mean is there
is there a sense i mean what fraction of
our language is is metaphorical has been
quantified
uh it hasn't been quantified and partly
because we don't know
of those metaphors how many of them are
dead metaphors that may have originated
as metaphors in the minds of the first
coiners the first poets the first
colorful speakers but have been uh
dumbly memorized ever since
but the answer is surely
most language at least historically and
you can just prove this by looking up
almost any word in the dictionary for an
abstract word and its root in in in
germanic and indo-european will uh refer
to something pretty concrete i did this
in my book the stuff of thought with the
opening of the declaration of
independence where almost every word
like it went in the course of human
affairs well course as in a water course
or a race course is is a pathway
and
word after word you dig deep enough and
you do find some concrete referent and i
think it is a profound observation and
indeed if i was to answer your your most
general question namely how did i a and
this this is a
uh puzzle that goes back to alfred
russell wallace the co-discoverer of the
theory of natural selection namely
presumably
if the selection contingencies that
shaped the human brain
certainly did not involve being able to
to do physics as we know it or or write
novels
how why are we capable of doing it how
did our brain evol how did our brain
evolve
in the
pleistocene that uh uh tens of thousands
of years later allows us to discover you
know black holes or to to to write
novels
and i think chomsky identified one of
the key engines and that is the
open-ended recursive combinatorial power
of language and by extension thought
that is
language does not consist of a list of
sentences that we memorize it is a set
of grammatical rules that allow us to
combine words and to embed combinations
in bigger combinations and still bigger
combinations without limit so there's no
finite limit on the number of
sentences we can utter but more
importantly
since each one of those sentences
conveys a thought there is no limit on
the number of thoughts we can think
i think the other key to answering that
question comes from
in a sense chomsky's
bet noir his uh long-time opponent
within the field of linguistics and
former student george lakoff uh from the
book metaphors we live by
who i identify the phenomenon that
impresses you and me namely that
language is just uh saturated to take
another metaphor with metaphor uh we
don't even realize it we say you know he
attacked my argument and i tried to
defend it well that's kind of appealing
to an underlying metaphor of argument is
war
and uh as soon as you start to notice
this you just see that that that
almost all of abstract language is
metaphorical
now so i i think that the
the the metaphorical abstraction where
we can take
ways of thinking that originally evolved
to for you know chucking rocks and for
for
for pushing logs
and extend it to these abstract realms
even something is as abstract as uh say
the
uh analogizing the value of a variable
to a location in space something that we
do every time we plot a graph
or to analog and analogize
uh application of force to change
to causation uh
immediately our concrete cognition can
be put to work for abstract scientific
uh deliberation
and then combine it with chomsky's
insight that there's just no limit to
the thoughts that we can think given
these combinatorial rules of embedding
one thought into another and you can you
see the provision for an explosion of
thought but there is one other piece to
the puzzle though because just being
able to think an infinite number of
thoughts and to have all of these
poetic metaphors can't explain why
science should ever work why should
given that you know a metaphor is just
our reaching for something familiar why
should it even apply to something as
abstruse as
the universe the fundamental forces the
elementary constituents of matter i mean
it just seems like an amazing
coincidence that a mind that there are a
cognition for rocks and sticks and and
uh
and
and shoving things should work in these
abstract domains and so there i think to
uh to to solve that puzzle i i um
appealed to an idea from a philosopher
named richard boyd which is that they're
the successful metaphors in science are
ones that are really more analogies than
metaphors and they appeal to some
abstract
uh relational system that embraces both
the
source of the metaphor and the thing
that you're explaining maybe you know
complexity theory or complex systems
theory would be the source of these
models but just to be give you a
concrete example
why would um
you know a a a tetherball
give us a good metaphor for the solar
system and then you know
and then even to some extent the adam
yeah the bore adam uh i mean
why did god make tetherballs which we
play with and know about a good model
for adams i mean that seems
did he want us to understand it well
presumably not presumably it's because
there is a
an entity abstract indie called say
centripetal systems which can be
characterized by
energy and force and geometry that
embrace
uh tether balls and solar systems and
atoms so it's not so much that they by
an amazing coincidence we can understand
an atom via a tetherball but just that
their the universe contains
systems that have many examples some of
which are accessible to our everyday
experience and our luck is that
our everyday experience can exemplify
these systems that also apply to much
bigger much smaller much more abstract
entities but the amazing thing there is
while there are echoes
of the phenomenon that take place on one
scale happening on other scales and
therefore allowing say the tetherball to
be a reasonable bottle for the earth
going around the sun when you do apply
it to atoms it works just so far right
it worked for the initial version and
then somehow we're able to use the power
of observation experiment and
mathematics to break free of the initial
metaphor
and come to a new understanding of the
world which then we invent yet new
metaphors to describe so there's a great
deal of flexibility that somehow is
built into this whole schema where
we're not locked in rigidly to only
recapitulating our understanding of one
scale on another scale is that telling
us something deep about the human mind
is that
some quality of mathematics that we've
developed and now we're allowing
mathematics to take us forward are we
learning more about ourselves or more
about the universe
yes no ab absolutely that's a vital
point and again
you and i as
would be science explainers are
constantly faced with the problem of
reaching for an analogy and the analogy
only goes so far and in fact if you take
it too seriously then you'll
misunderstand the phenomenon and i know
i mean when when the the higgs boson was
uh confirmed the metaphors some of them
were just seemed so
crummy that they
you know running past a
crowd and slapping people's hands and
you know molasses and i mean i i've used
molasses so don't don't don't diss
molasses here
okay
glasses is fine no no it actually has
some problems i agree
no but you're absolutely right that the
uh in addition to metaphorical or
analogical thinking
the mind has to be nimble enough to
compartmentalize the analogy and to pick
out what aspects are
uh ought to be taken seriously and which
ones ought to be ignored that requires a
pretty sophisticated kind of
representational computational uh system
a kind of a logical form with
variables that can be bound but also
unbound i mean it speaks i think to the
sophistication of thought that we can
both
enjoy and appreciate an analogy but uh
also know how or ideally
know what aspects to attend to and which
ones to ignore absolutely vital so so we
spoke a little bit before about the
origin of language generally
where
did the first metaphors come from i mean
is that a separate question i mean
presumably language began in a very
to use a metaphor concrete way we were
actually speaking about specific things
in the physical world around us
at what point
did a metaphorical version of the
language start to inject itself to use
another metaphor and and and and thereby
give us this distinct way of describing
things in the world
well it may that step may not have been
that hard if we
mentally represent things not as an
unanalyzed glob a gestalt but if we
represent it in terms of its
constituents its components
its shape its weight its it's motion
then
two things that actually share
components
will
automatically call one another to mind
might literally
be represented in overlapping neural
real estate that is if we think of and
you mean literally literally here
literally literally yeah exactly
literally literally i mean it could be
that that
in fact there is the
challenge of how you don't confuse them
but if for example you
see a um
see a tetherball and it isn't just
the the tetherball scene
but you represent it as oh there's an
object and the object spins and the
trajectory is a circle and there's
something uh pulling it
and then if you see say an animation of
an atom
and the way that it's represented in the
mind again is not just
adam you know full stop but oh it's got
as an object in the
big object in the center and a little
one in the periphery and
uh an invisible line of force connecting
it and it goes around in a circle then
you've got circle and circle and line
and line an object and object
it might be quite natural for one of
them to
trigger the other it may be even
automatic if say your representation of
object is just say even in an extreme
case let's say it's just one place in
the brain and then you think adam
you think uh ball
and
parts of those thoughts might literally
overlap so that part that part might be
easier in fact probably the
computational challenge in terms of
neural computation is how do you not
confuse them right now you mentioned
and we've been playing around with it
that
metaphors do die at some point in the
sense that we no longer sort of hear
them as metaphors you just hear them as
words describing things in the world and
of course one way to establish that is
just to look at the number of times
people mix metaphors in ways that just
don't make any sense and i was just
looking at a few examples that i had
written down you know people have
written burning the bridge at both ends
biting off the wrong end of the stick
here's one that i loved it was the
bottom of the ninth so they threw a hail
mary
i mean that's got so many
interconnected parts i don't even know
where to make sense of that another one
that's a pet peeve of mine
they invested heavily in the company
resulting in earnings taking a quantum
leap
that's a funny one because i get it
quantum leap is a leap that couldn't
happen in the classical world but a
quantum leap is the smallest possible
leap at all and one that i'd never heard
before i read in your book that maybe
you can remind us of
one that rabbi baruch korff
wrote in referring to to nixon do you do
you recall that one by any chance
how how could i forget that the um
the american press has literally
emasculated the president yes right
right um making him eligible for the the
club called uh awful americans who
figuratively use literally there you go
and and so is there a sense of
how long it takes for a metaphor to die
it's not like a a constant and it
depends i think on how many contexts
it's used in
whether people hear it uh divorced from
its original context in which case since
we can
we have
the ability this is a another elementary
principle of linguistics one of the
foundations is just arbitrary signs that
is one of the things that makes language
so powerful is that we can associate a
sound with a meaning
now often those sounds have a
transparent relationship to the meaning
as in metaphors as in onomatopoeia
as in to some extent in what's sometimes
called uh phonetic symbolism the fact
that humongous is refers to big things
and teensy refers to little things kind
of echoing the or the size of the cavity
in your mouth so there can be some
connections
on the other hand we'd be quite crippled
in communication if every one of our
words had to be like a pantomime where
you could just sort of see what it meant
just by its shape we can do these
arbitrary memorizations
tens of thousands of them and so what
originated as a transparent metaphor if
people just
don't see the connection they just
memorize it the same way you memorize
that the word for english for dog in
english is dog i mean the word dog
doesn't you know look like a dog or bark
like a dog
we just all memorized it and we can do
that and sometimes we do it too much as
in the case of mixed metaphors
is there
some sense i mean we talk about words
themselves in fact that we memorize them
there's some connection to the external
world
is in there the answer to the question
which i i've puzzled around and i think
i asked you this once when we were
together a couple years ago
if you look up a given word in the
dictionary it's defined in terms of
other words in the dictionary so this
book kind of seems somewhat
circular right
is the way out of that that there are
certain words that somehow
are
so basic and so
uh within our need to know and just to
live in the world that we understand
them without a dictionary and that's
what breaks the loop is is that where
the answer comes from
uh abs yes absolutely
part of the answer and this is connected
to your answer is that of course some
words in the dictionary have little
pictures next to them
uh so that that breaks the circle
uh also because dictionaries are
intended for
human users who
bring all of their intelligence common
sense expectations to bear when reading
the dictionary you could they uh we draw
on a lot of our tacit knowledge in
figuring out um
what a word means from its definition in
those cases where we have to look it up
in the first place the vast majority of
words of course we learn from experience
but yes we hear a word in context we uh
now there's an old theory that
it's just raw association that like
almost like pavlovian conditioning you
hear the word you see the uh the action
and so word action word action or word
object word object
chances are that's
that's not the way we do it
uh for example when a child is told to
stop doing something then you know the
word stop can't refer to what the child
is doing by definition
the the extra level of sophistication is
that we use our intuitive psychology our
so-called theory of mind
referring now to not a scientific theory
but an intuitive theory to make a
reasonable guess as to what what the
speaker
is probably trying to get across
and then we uh solve the puzzle of what
sound it coming out of the speaker's
mouth or our hands in the case of of
signing
probably is what the speaker was trying
to convey so there has to be enough
redundancy
in the situations especially in the case
of of uh children
that they can that language is
partly redundant redundant enough that
they can crack the code and figure out
what those words mean
but indeed
not only sensory experiences just you
can't define red at the end of the day
red is just you know what what what
triggers your long wavelength cones
and likewise there may be a
a kind of almost an alphabet of
elementary concepts
uh what what computer scientists
sometimes call an ontology uh in the
case of representations of the basic
ideas and relationships
that are form the basis of all of this
metaphorical stuff that we can then
elaborate so maybe
elementary things like an object
a causation
a place a path
and there are linguists like ray
jackendoff i've tried to to do it myself
to
lay down what is this inventory what is
at the end of the day the language of
thought which in a sense is not itself
language but it is the
system for
understanding and reasoning about the
world and each other that language then
externalizes
so so we spoke a little bit about
dead metaphors
we spoke a bit about metaphors and
analogies as they play a role in science
where it's a very
specific tool to allow us to say go from
one level of understanding to a
different level of understanding
but what makes
a live metaphor a metaphor that just we
we we look at in awe at the author
having written this phrase about the
world what is it about those kinds of
metaphors that just move us as emotional
beings
yeah they it um
excellent question at the intersection
of
um cognitive science including
linguistics and you know poetics and and
literature what makes for a a brilliant
metaphor
it's probably a combination of its
aptness in terms of the
relational structure and this is partly
what makes for a good scientific analogy
and here i'm drawing on the work of the
cognitive psychologist dendri gentner
that
the
what makes a
the flow of
liquid a good
analogy for thermodynamics
is not that you know water can be hot in
fact that you got to forget that water
is hot uh you've got to have
abstract concepts like a a potential
difference and flow
and uh to the extent that the
structure of what causes what and what
enables what and what prevents what if
all of those abstract relationships
carry over from the thing you're
describing and the thing you're reaching
for
that makes an analogy or a metaphor feel
deep
in addition
that's that's what makes a good
scientific analogy what makes for a good
literary metaphor is if in addition
the the affect the emotion conveyed by
the
uh
the vehicle or the uh uh
sheds light on the emotion that we feel
toward the the target or as they call it
the the tenor
uh so the the emotional connection is
crucial and there are uh
i i illustrate this in the stuff of
thought
uh by its opposite the bad metaphor
contest from the washington post that
they had a number of years ago where
people would submit humorously
inappropriate metaphors like
he
uh
he took his life and jumped out the
window and hit the ground like a hefty
bag filled with tomato soup
now
it's kind of in conspicuously bad taste
and it is a bad metaphor because that's
precisely not the kind of connotation
that you want um in conveying something
as precious as a human life
uh so did he say you can understand
something by seeing what it's not those
bad metaphors uh underscore what is
wrong with a metaphor like that whereas
something like i am the you know nabokov
i am the shadow of the waxwing slain
by the false azure of the window pane
where he's talking about the loss of uh
his own
uh emotional
uh crushing evisceration of the death of
a daughter analogizing it to a bird that
flies into a pane of glass
where they're the
patheticness of the the pathos of the
the bird something that we feel as
beautiful as fragile as delicate
being um it was
misled by
a a transparent window and seeing blue
on the other side
uh there's something so poignant about a
blue sky a beautiful bird leading
to its death
and so not only is the
content
uh transparent but every one of the
emotions elicited by the metaphor the
azure the the the falseness
uh the shadow uh each one of them
triggers an emotion that's appropriate
to what's being uh conveyed in this case
the the death of a child
well i was i myself was moved by another
choice that you made in illustrating
powerful metaphors and the stuff of
thought i recently reread
madame bovary i'd read it of course as a
student a long time ago and there was
one passage in in my copy that i'd
heavily underscored
i don't underscore a whole lot and then
i saw that passage in your book so i
thought it was fitting to end with this
passage which goes
no one can ever give the exact measure
of his needs nor of his conceptions nor
of his sorrows as human language is like
a cracked tin kettle on which we hammer
out tunes to make bears dance
when we long
to move the stars
and so with that stephen pinker thank
you so much for joining us i enjoyed
this conversation on language and uh
thanks a lot
always a pleasure thanks for having me
brian thank you
four distinct views on language from
four of the foremost thinkers on the
subject
language as a tool of inner thought
language as a socially constructed means
for instructing the imagination of
others and language as the natural
evolutionary outcome of humankind
filling the cognitive niche now there
are profound differences between these
perspectives but there is also common
ground the fact that we humans are able
to use language to understand so much
about the cosmos and about ourselves
that to me
is just wondrous
i'm brian greene thank you for joining
us and join us again for future episodes
in this world science festival series
focusing
on the big ideas of science
[Music]
do
[Music]
you